they've been a consistent presence in
afghanistan for over 25 years
but following the us withdrawal from the
country the taliban stunned the world in
how quickly it took over i think it's a
procession of
of the taliban
yes it is there's the white flag
and
they're coming down
the street
as afghanistan prepares for the militia
to rule the country once again
who exactly are the group and what do
they believe in
the taliban are an islamist military
organization which ruled afghanistan
from 1996 until 2001
[Music]
they believe in a hard-line
interpretation of sharia law and want to
restore their strict approach to the
governance of the country
for two decades they've fought against
the internationally recognized
government of afghanistan
it's taken a few minutes to put it into
this culvert
and you really can't tell that it's been
there certainly not in the dark
in the early 1990s the soviet union was
successfully pushed out of afghanistan
by resistance fighters known as the
mujahideen
these fighters were funded and supported
by the cia as well as other western
powers
in the civil war that followed the
taliban was the most prominent group
that emerged and successfully took over
the country
theirs was a repressive regime where
women and girls were denied education
music and films were banned
and massacres and executions commonplace
afghanistan also became a training
ground for terrorists
after 9 11 the u.s wanted them to hand
over the man responsible
[Music]
osama bin laden who had trained in
afghanistan
they refused so the u.s invaded toppled
the taliban and installed a government
which they hoped would be able to run
the country on its own
the taliban regime
is coming to an end
their leader is haibatullah akhen zada
he has ultimate control over political
religious and military affairs
muller abdulgani bharada is the deputy
leader and co-founded the taliban he now
heads the political office and is part
of their negotiating team with the
americans
surajudin haqqani is the head of the
haqqani network
the u.s have called it a terrorist group
and it's infamous for its use of suicide
bombers
the taliban have commissions
essentially departments of finance
health military education and others
underneath this cabinet of leaders are
local commanders
in power across the country's provincial
capitals under their control
who are responsible for everyday
services
among ordinary afghans support for the
taliban has decreased in afghanistan in
the last decade
in 2009 a survey found that just over
half the population had sympathy with
armed opposition groups such as the
taliban
but in 2019 the same survey found that
85 of afghans had little sympathy for
the taliban
the speed at which the taliban has
overtaken the afghan military
suggests there may have been less
resistance amongst the population than
previously thought
[Music]
the group has promised to allow a free
media and they've said women and girls
will be safe
indeed in some provinces local
commanders have allowed girls education
to continue
this is not the case everywhere though
and there is no guarantee this is
indicative of their approach elsewhere
[Music]
after 20 years of western powers
attempting to bring democracy and
freedom to afghanistan
it appears the sudden withdrawal of
troops has left it all in vain
for some it was a fruitless endeavor
which took too long
for others
it was a rushed conclusion to an ongoing
project that has left millions at risk
[Music]
you